Olá e bem-vindos a todos, este é
o fluxo de convidados de inferência ativa 28.1, é
14 de outubro de 2022.
hoje vamos ouvir e
discutir a reconceituação da racionalidade de
Giovanni Rolla, então Giovanni, muito
obrigado por participar, muito
ansioso por esta apresentação e
discussão.
obrigado obrigado então foi um prazer
receber o seu convite há alguns
meses e estou muito feliz por estar aqui
para ter esta oportunidade de discutir o meu
trabalho
hum vou poupar o seu pedido
hum a nossa sugestão estou a apresentar
isto  artigo que escrevi há alguns anos
e enquanto estávamos conversando nos bastidores
eu mudei de ideia algumas
vezes e vou deixar isso claro
durante a apresentação desde que
publiquei esse artigo, mas é um
prazer  mesmo assim ter a chance
de apresentar este vídeo aqui e uh
compartilhá-lo com o mundo então estou muito
feliz
uh então vamos falar sobre
reconceber a racionalidade e este é o
este é o
itinerário  Eu estava pensando em
apresentar a você, então primeiro eu vou
falar sobre racionalidade e
cognição sem conteúdo, então eu vou apresentar
minha visão que eu chamei de
racionalidade radicalmente inativa e palavras de segurança
sobre agência e interação proficiente
e raciocínio e racionalidade eles estão
próximos de um casal  de objecções a
primeira é que
tudo o que estou aqui presente é um verdadeiro
liberal de uma forma excessivamente liberal
engloba demasiado e a segunda
objecção que penso ser a que
mais vos pode interessar é
se é compatível com os efeitos  com o
processo preditivo em nossa codificação preditiva, que
é claro nas instalações
perto dos dois carros no centro
para influenciar ativamente,
então
aqui está o desculpe,
meus pensamentos iniciais sobre o assunto são
que tradicionalmente os
ortodoxos  ter uma visão sobre a racionalidade
uh assume até onde eu
sei é como uma suposição realmente que a
racionalidade deve em seu raciocínio
que por exemplo  ance eu acredito que B em uma
ação a são racionais se e somente se
houver o raciocínio que subscreve
o Bure então e é claro que não é apenas
qualquer raciocínio que a questão do raciocínio
deve adquirir com certos
pontos de referência formais, como lógica clássica
ou raciocínio probabilístico ou
heurísticas tão acreditando e agindo
racionalmente de acordo com este filme tradicional
requerem o cumprimento de certos padrões formais
e isso, como eu disse, parece-me ser em
grande parte uma suposição sobre o que
significa ser racional ao definir a
racionalidade em termos de raciocínio,
então se a racionalidade requer raciocínio
e  se o raciocínio envolve a avaliação
de crenças contra certos referenciais formais,
então a racionalidade implica
conteúdo para cognição
onde o conteúdo que eu considero
ter condições mínimas de precisão ser capaz
de estar
certo ou errado ou em uma
noção mais pesada sendo verdadeiro ou falso, então
o  A ideia aqui é que a racionalidade
necessariamente envolve conteúdo, envolve
crenças  raciocínio e a comparação ou
desculpe atualizar agora
uma atualização de software desculpe, houve
um pop-up na minha janela aqui, então,
isso seria eu acho que a
visão padrão da racionalidade
e
se é assim que a racionalidade
envolve necessariamente  conteúdo, é um bom ajuste
com o cognitivismo clássico ou
cognitivismo em geral,
que é a visão de que a combinação
envolve necessariamente
conteúdo representacional, pelo menos para alguns
cognitivistas, é claro, pode envolver
também
um conteúdo conceitual, mas, no
mínimo, conteúdo representacional que tem
condições de precisão,
mas essa visão clássica não é tão boa
que não fornece um ajuste tão bom com a
cognição radicalmente inativa e incorporada
que estou aqui pensando não
especificamente no radical e no ativismo de
Goodwin Maine nos livros recentes, mas
acho que também desafia outros  pontos de vista
que não são apresentados como radicais e
ativos, mas é claro que eles compartilham alguns
inquilinos centrais com radicais e ativistas.  sm
podemos chamá-los de visões radicalmente incorporadas
de cognições, como
um com as visões apresentadas por Ezekiel
Powell ou Berman
modelo de vida sensorial você também tem
a variedade de inativismo de Gallagher em seu
livro de 2017 e também a visão
de Tony kimero em seu  livro de 2009 sobre
psicologia ecológica e
sistemas dinâmicos todos eles compartilham inquilinos comuns
e aqui estou eu sei que isso é muito
controverso, mas estou tratando essas
visões como visões radicalmente incorporadas da
cognição e estou especificamente
focado em visões radicais e ativas da
culinária
todos eles dizem que não o reconhecimento é
representacional com conteúdo, o que é de
certa forma dizer que podemos pensar em
formas básicas de cognição
sem conteúdo ou em um nível sem conteúdo nível básico de
reconhecimento
que emerge através da
exploração ativa de seu ambiente e
além do radical e do ativismo por  o que queremos
dizer com
isso pode ser essa ideia pode ser
aproveitada em termos de dominar os envolvimentos sensório-motores
uma questão de saber  -como
o saber se envolver com o seu
entorno em vez de saber que as
coisas estão assim e assim ao seu redor, então isso
é muito claramente o que Paulo e
colegas e uh kimero, por exemplo, fazem
em seus livros uh radical e o ativismo
tem uma certa tendência a distorcer
envolvimentos de modelos sensoriais Esquemas de modelos sensoriais
Etc
e uh,
mas desenvolvimentos recentes, eu acho,
incorporaram que isso é o
uso da essência dessa ideia,
então se combinarmos visões incorporadas radicais
de ruminação ou radical e ativismo
e o combustível clássico em  racionalidade
o que temos é algo que o ângulo
descreveu da seguinte forma
um ativismo é a visão de que a cognição
é fundamentada em uma oração
compreensão racional do mundo que é baseada
na aquisição sensório-motora da
situação da vida real
e ele explica essas uh essa ideia de
pré-  compreensão racional
por
um
por meio das ideias do melopentino
Heidegger segundo o qual a relação
com o mundo pode ser apenas uma enraizada em
p  A prática dos inativos na atuação e na
prática interna é mediada
pelo corpo, então o que parece estar implícito
aqui é que, diferentemente da ação e da prática, a
racionalidade não é realmente
algo que não está em um
nível muito básico de combinação, então foi isso
que aconteceu quando nós
abrir espaço para um nível básico de cognição
enraizado no ativo e na prática e
separá-lo dos níveis superiores de
combinação que eles geralmente são o
locus o sortudo clássico da racionalidade de
modo que
a ideia em resumo é aquela
cognição contenciosa ou cognição básica
que emerge através do sensorial
engajamentos motores não são racionais,
portanto, engajamentos modernos sensoriais, no entanto, as
virtudes em prolíficos podem ser não podem
ser avaliadas do ponto de vista da
racionalidade apenas conteúdo para cognição
combinação de alto nível pode ser
definição racional que é expressa, por
exemplo, em crenças e recentemente
e bem, isso é algo  que
eu não toquei no papel, mas
foi minha motivação implícita para d  lidar com
este assunto
como alguém que vem da filosofia
da mente é a ideia do mito do
dado pelo menos uma versão dele
me pareceu na época e uh fui
corretamente persuadido por um revisor a não
tocar no assunto  foi muito
complicado na minha apresentação inicial,
mas parece-me que se dividirmos o
reconhecimento básico de um pensamento
e ação racional e não apontarmos para
o
poço, não há, quero dizer, interseção
entre esses dois níveis, parece que
radical e ativismo e  uh
visões semelhantes estariam comprometidas com o mito
do dado impopularizado por Sellers e
moderações de McDowell como um problema para
campos imperiosos da minha mente,
então parece que isso é eu acho que
[Música]
um problema filosoficamente interessante,
mas não é algo que é  uh, na
frente do artigo, foi minha
motivação implícita aqui que, para explicar
como podemos combinar o nível de cognição sem conteúdo ou
básico através de
compromissos sensoriais modernos com razão  nalidade se
você não pode parece que uh há um
dado de algum tipo que não está sendo
uh completamente explicado em nossa imagem
da mente então isso é algo que eu
queria eu ainda quero tentar explorar
essa intuição mais claramente mas eu
tenho  Eu não
toquei nisso,
mas eu acho que há algo na
direção de por que o que eu vou mostrar
hoje é uma maneira de diminuir
essa acusação de estar comprometido
com o mito do dado,
então como podemos reconceber a racionalidade, quero
dizer  Acho que para evitar esse
problema e evitar a ideia de que temos
dois níveis completamente separados
um do outro, onde um O Superior é
o locus da racionalidade clássica e o que
mais está abaixo dele não é racional,
acho que a ideia é rejeitar a
racionalidade  deve ser definido ou
implica necessariamente raciocínio
não precisa ainda ser concebido, mas
então o desafio passa a ser oferecer uma
proposta positiva do que é racionalidade se não
raciocínio e aqui está Susan H  urley em um
artigo que meu conhecimento é o único
que é
sobre esse assunto e acho que ela
também se preocupou com o mito do
dado pelo caminho na época e ele é uma
longa citação daqui fenomide eu
lendo isso é essa racionalidade  pode
emergir de um sistema complexo de
relações hierárquicas centralizadas de
facilitação de inibição e coordenação
entre diferentes camadas horizontais Cada uma
das quais é uma racionalidade dinâmica e ambientalmente
situada reconcebida em
termos horizontais ou modulares uh eu não
sei se ela tem que usar essa
terminologia mas  de qualquer forma, foi assim que ela
escolheu expressá-lo está
relacionado de forma sustentável com o ambiente não
depende apenas de procedimentos internos que
mediam entre entrada e saída como
conteúdo para o organismo como um
todo ou para um
módulo cognitivo central verticalmente limitado, mas
depende de  relacionamentos complexos entre o
mundo dedicado envolvendo camadas que
monitoram e respondem a aspectos específicos
do n  ambiente natural e social
e da rede neural e reduzir
o feedback de suas respostas,
este é o primeiro caso de
alguém trabalhando na abordagem inativa
de uma
maneira obviamente mais
associada ao trabalho de
avano, que também é ativista, mas
em uma abordagem diferente do radical e do
ativismo e aqui está o mais antigo
e ao meu conhecimento antes de escrever esse
artigo é que a proposta mais clara
de racionalidade reconcebida
nos termos nativos, mas não é
algo que ganhou força
após sua publicação para  meu conhecimento
na verdade eu não vi muito desde então
e para resumir a idéia é que
temos que mudar o Foco explicativo
que é a racionalidade não é
pensada exclusivamente como um Conteúdo envolvendo
capacidade nesta proposta está situada
ou Mundo envolvido em mundos aumentados
e é radicalmente corporificado
depende da morfologia e ação corporal
e de como o organismo se situa e
age  s nesse ambiente a ideia
estará minimamente morta então isso é o que eu chamo de
racionalidade radicalmente inativa
é uh em uma
definição muito vaga até agora é que um asiático
age racionalmente na medida em que o ser humano
mantém uma interação proficiente com
seu ambiente coordenando suas
habilidades cognitivas  de acordo com
as condições ambientais de constrangimentos
e estações sólidas e claro que isso
às vezes requer adaptação a
circunstâncias imprevistas a
intuição central é esta
e é interessante comparar esta
ideia de racionalidade radical e ativa
com outra das ideias de Susan Hurley
num texto de 2003 que ela  ela diz
razões uh para agir que ela argumenta
que as razões para agir podem estar
vinculadas ao contexto onde ela está argumentando contra a
restrição de generalidade uh Gareth Evans
e isso é a defesa da ideia de
ilhas de racionalidade prática
então ela ainda está tratando a racionalidade como
essencialmente algo que se relaciona  ao
raciocínio aqui, mas esse tipo de
raciocínio é limitado  d pelo contexto prático,
então essa é uma visão muito Progressista
se comparada com a
visão tradicional que eu falei no começo,
mas ainda mais conservadora do que a que
estou tentando desenvolver aqui,
então outra coisa que eu acho que deve estar
lá na vanguarda disso  A proposta
é que a racionalidade implica agência e
autonomia porque algo ou apenas
algo que um organismo faz pode ser
dito ser racional,
então usar essas ideias do
campo autônomo e ativista e
da teoria de como os jogadores são
sistemas autônomos como  um Roomba
não pode ser racional porque não é um
agente não é o autor do seu próprio
comportamento foi concebido por
agentes externos para funcionar de uma certa maneira por isso
não é estritamente falando uma nação por isso
é onde eu desenharia a linha de onde
bem  você não pode não faz sentido
atribuir racionalidade a um Roomba por
exemplo
e
para isso
eu uso as Noções de autonomia e
adaptabilidade do DiPaolo e outros você
tem um  Também a imagem do livro recente, a
vida do modelo sensorial dos quatro e aquele famoso
artigo da tigela de 2005, onde ele
fala sobre a adaptabilidade
para definir suas restrições muito gerais
sobre o que significa ser russo,
para que os sistemas autônomos sejam
concebidos como redes precárias.
rede precária de processos porque a
organização e os limites físicos são
produzidos pelo próprio sistema o sistema
está continuamente mantendo suas próprias
condições de viabilidade, o que é
conhecido como criação de sentido, onde o
sistema explorou
as condições ambientais ambientais que são
favoráveis ​​à sua auto-manutenção e
evita os que lhe são prejudiciais
então é assim que eu entendo ser
o próprio em geral que eles
constrangimento emocional em um ser racional
que deve ser um sistema autônomo
e o interessante aqui é que
o conceito de adaptabilidade que Paulo mas
é que a capacidade de um
organismo de melhorar sua condição
de autoprodução por meio  h
mudanças estruturais internas,
então envolve o monitoramento e
regulação das mudanças internas
para selecionar o melhor curso de
ação disponível, eu acho que é outro
conceito interessante para se pensar para
incluir essa ideia de uma
noção radicalmente inativa de racionalidade que
não está necessariamente comprometido com o
raciocínio e o conteúdo, de
modo que a agência é realizada através do
exercício de habilidades situadas que
promovem mudanças dentro do organismo de
acordo com
restrições e subestações ambientais, o
que significa que quão bem um organismo se
adapta para lidar
com proficiência com seu ambiente é uma medida  ou
uma indicação de sua racionalidade, quanto
mais racional um organismo é, mais
apto ele está para lidar com seu
ambiente e nós previmos
circunstâncias
e, ao fazê-lo, o organismo potencializa
as trocas contínuas entre ele
e o ambiente
que são cruciais para sua sobrevivência e
é uma
maneira muito naturalizada de pensar a
racionalidade  é principalmente a capacidade de
melhorar as mudanças para a sobrevivência
esta é
a ideia geral aqui
então como eu disse antes e sobre o raciocínio
eu quero
eu não quero comprometer a racionalidade
necessariamente com o raciocínio e é disso
que se trata a racionalidade radicalmente inativa
mas eu  não quero excluir o
raciocínio como uma combinação racional anterior,
então o que estou dizendo é que
não é definido pelo raciocínio, mas
não exclui o
raciocínio, acho que seria pensado como
um modo especial ou específico de
agência racional  um que é exclusivo do nosso
conhecimento para os seres humanos,
mas não é a característica definidora da
racionalidade,
então para isso eu uh, a fim de explicar
essa ideia, lembro como Hutu e
Saturno entre o artigo no livro mais recente
de utani, eles explicam o  surgimento
de alto reconhecimento a ideia é que
ser capaz de se engajar em conteúdo para
cognição depende, em última análise, de ser
social e culturalmente incorporado
onde a cognição plena do conteúdo emergiu
da sociedade.  A interação cultural inicial, de modo que
um indivíduo participa de
práticas socioculturais,
ele aceita habilidades cognitivas mais antigas
para lidar com símbolos e, ao
fazê-lo, está
em um longo processo de inculturação, é
claro,
ele se torna capaz de se engajar com
uma coordenação simbólica que não é
interna  representação específica
porque está publicamente disponível não são
representações mentais no sentido tradicional,
mas tem as características da
cognição simbólica sem o compromisso com
a representação interna ou representações mentais,
então agir racionalmente em seu sentido mais geral
é a ideia de que o
comportamento proficiente de um  organismo está em uh é é
o comportamento proficiente de um organismo
em seu ambiente depende da
coordenação das habilidades incorporadas ao
passo que o raciocínio se tudo correr
bem é entendido como conteúdo
para a racionalidade para o meu modo específico de
racionalidade o raciocínio é o
comportamento proficiente de um  organismo em um ambiente
sociocultural  meio ambiente
que é um aspecto mais específico do nosso
ambiente, é claro, e depende
da coordenação de tal culturalmente
baseado ou conteúdo envolvendo habilidades
que são mais recentes na escala filogenética humana
tão bem isso é o maior da
ideia este é o
a parte propositiva e aqui estão
as objeções sobre as quais eu queria falar a
primeira é que é uma visão muito liberal
é muito
uh é bem que engloba muito
se diria porque se a ação racional se
resume à coordenação  de
habilidades cognitivas então a racionalidade é
algo gradual pois um organismo pode
ser mais ou menos proficiente em suas
interações ambientais
e a rejeição vai de acordo com a
racionalidade radicalmente inativa muitos
organismos alcançam e mantêm um
comportamento adaptativo no nicho com
diferentes níveis de sucesso para o qual eu
estou bem, alguém poderia cantar racionalidades racionais
e ativas radicais e ativas
para Liberal e isso é  uma
objeção que eu ouvi pessoalmente
e guardei com tanta força porque acho
que é muito, é uma maneira muito boa de
colocar até as unhas são racionais
nessa visão e na qual devo dizer
que estou disposto a comprar  a carteira
uh bem, sim, é mais liberal do que
as visões tradicionais, é claro que se
destina a ser assim, mas não acho que
esse problema em si o que eu acho seja a
parte positiva aqui é que
preserva uma diferença de grau que os
humanos são  muito mais racionais do que outros
animais simplesmente porque somos capazes de
realizar uma grande variedade de ações em uma
ampla variedade de circunstâncias dinâmicas
que são muito além de quaisquer outros animais
que conhecemos,
então, para voltar ao exemplo deste
prego, este prego pode  realizar algumas
acções complexas pode mover-se de um ponto para
outro pode procurar comida e
abrigo e assim por diante mas eles têm
um conjunto crítico limitado de habilidades
se cercar este prego com o Sul
por exemplo está fadado a morrer por
a réplica e os humanos, por outro
lado, eles são muito mais adaptáveis ​​e
capazes de lidar dinamicamente com muitas
circunstâncias imprevistas, então,
em minha resposta a essa objeção, é que
sim,
bem, é muito liberal, mas esse
não é o problema, o problema seria se
isso  é se tivesse espaço para uma
diferença de grau entre a forma como os animais
lidam com os seus ambientes
assim e e esta é a outra
objecção do objecto que eu acho que pode ser
a que mais lhe interessa
então sabe é o processamento preditivo 12
parece implicar inferências e conteúdo por
todo o caminho
uh, mas primeiro devo uh avisar a vocês e
aos espectadores que
na época em que escrevi isso uh este artigo
era muito mais otimista sobre essa
possibilidade de combinar um ativismo e
codificação preditiva ou
processamento preditivo e uh  Eu acho que há
pontos importantes aqui, mas há este
artigo recente de Olu e Evan Thompson
e cerveja Randy onde eles
fornecem uma avaliação crítica de uh th
e as tentativas de combinar principalmente
o princípio da energia livre e
teorias
inativas e
autobiográficas, então agora estou
mais convencido pelos argumentos, mas
acho que há alguns pontos interessantes
de comparação aqui, no
entanto, processo preditivo em nosso
código preditivo e, uh, no  tempo em que eu escrevia
e ainda hoje está na moda nas
ciências cognitivas, acho que você pode
dizer que parecia doce se tornar
um dos principais paradigmas por aí,
então é interessante ver se ele
se encaixa bem com o que eu  estou falando
e nesses telespectadores você sabe que a
competição é entendida como um processo
de minimização de erros que ocorre em
hierarquias estreitas bidirecionais
então
você tem a geração de
modelos internos para a atividade das camadas inferiores
que antecipa as causas distais de
estímulos sinistros o que é um
processo de cima para baixo e a minimização da
discrepância entre a previsão e
o sinal de estímulo atual por
meio da ocupação de anteriores que  é uma
parte inferior do processo,
então aqui está, é claro, a inferência ativa
que é entendida, por exemplo,
em termos formais informais de
Clark que um organismo move seus sensores
de maneiras que equivalem a buscar ativamente em
nossa geração, gerando as
consequências sensoriais que eles são bastante  seus
cérebros esperam que
esta seja uma maneira de entender a influência ativa em
termos muito formais, mas
acho que faz o trabalho,
então é o cérebro inferindo a
fonte esperada de estímulos recebidos,
se parecer que há um
problema com o que estou  falando sobre
isso, a leitura de votação do
processamento preditivo, que é o que usa o
viés do produto e o direito de inferência, diz,
por exemplo, que o processo dos
percepcionistas é separável do
processo de propensão racional mais amplo de
prolificação e dos efeitos de cima para baixo do contexto.
processar isso chamou minha
atenção do jeito que Clark também está
falando sobre racionalidade o tempo todo,
mas é um  n tipo inferencial de
racionalidade
e raciocínio de influência
pervasiva parece implicar conteúdo abrangente
e, em seguida, o processamento preditivo parece
ser incompatível com a racionalidade radicalmente inativa
bem, mas há uh na
época e acho que ainda podemos argumentar em
vários dos não há
não  -hemorróidas e leitura de
processamento preditivo
que usa, por exemplo, um primeiro passo
seria usar um senso de deflação de
previsão que entendendo cameo em um
pequeno artigo de 2013, mas quarto, onde
os valores de duas ou mais variáveis
covariam ou são de valor confiável para que o
valor de 1 permite ao Observador inferir
o valor de outra e aqui a
inferência está acontecendo no
nível da observação não em uma
variável distante está inferindo o valor de
outra então a ideia seria eu acho
que o conteúdo está nos olhos de  o
espectador a pessoa que interpreta como
a seleção de censorial que colocamos
aproxima as previsões internas aqui
entendidas em t  O sentido inflacionário pode
descrevê-lo em termos inferenciais e tendenciosos
, então é assim que vejo, por exemplo,
a idéia sobre 4 000 do
artigo de Bruno que, se não me engano, o
título é algo como o cérebro não é
um cientista e o argumento está em  essa
direção geral
que estamos projetando como os
cientistas interpretam a atividade cerebral como uma
característica do próprio cérebro como se
estivesse prevendo e inferindo esse sentido mais
robusto ou mais pesado,
então o que estou tentando dizer aqui é que
inferência ativa, então eu uso duplo  e
dizer que o dobro esqueceu o nome disso em
inglês desculpe
hum, não é o sentido literal de
inferência aqui de acordo com a racionalidade radicalmente
inativa
uh é que desarmado para a
eficiência do comportamento co-orientado o
agente tem que agir de certas
maneiras para que seu  seus Estados se
frutifiquem de forma mais eficiente e menos onerosa,
isso não implica a afirmação mais controversa de
que os próprios modelos generativos
exibem e realizam
inferências preditivas  es esta é uma
leitura muito deflacionária no
processamento preditivo para fornecer essa
combinação com racionalidade radical e ativa
e aqui está um pontapé inicial em um artigo de
por modelo não segue que um
organismo tenha um
modelo representacional interno de seu nicho na
medida em que  é esse modelo que esses são o
trabalho cognitivo se você preferir um
organismo é um modelo que é as
regularidades causais e estatísticas refletem em
algum ambiente refletindo algum
fenótipo que é um modelo
e bem
isso se relaciona com algo que recentemente
uh meu colega notifica e eu  tenho
falado sobre a ideia de como os
organismos criam um mundo de acordo com um
ativismo que é a ideia de que o organismo
e o ambiente são
historicamente chamados historicamente determinados, então
na escala genética do fluxo isso poderia
ser explicado através da ideia de construção de nicho
a ideia de que uma vez  um
organismo é ativo em seu ambiente, ele
promove mudanças que, se forem
suficientemente estáveis,  Eles podem ser herdados por sua
descendência e essas mudanças fornecem novas
pressões de pressão evolucionária
que lideram seu caminho evolutivo
uma ideia semelhante também foi explorada por
outra descrição desta vez relacionando a
construção de nicho
e a psicologia ecológica,
então minha resposta a essa objeção é
que agir racionalmente significa alcançar
um envolvimento proficiente com o
meio ambiente através de uma forma de previsão
e sua minimização Estou disposto a
aceitar essa caracterização, mas
processos racionais e tendenciosos mais amplos
não precisam implicar conteúdo para cognição
se entendermos isso no Flash
previsão sem sentido e sua minimização
envolvem a seleção de entrada e a
coordenação de uma interabilidade nas
maneiras de envolvimento com o mundo, o que é
exatamente a principal reivindicação da personalidade radical e
ativa, então acho que nessa
medida o processamento preditivo não é
um inimigo que seria antes  do que uma
mentira dessa ideia em vez de uh
chegada mas de c  temos outras
questões de compatibilidade que eu
não abordei aqui, mas isso é
tudo que eu pensei por hoje
obrigado incrível muito obrigado
tudo bem
legal muito interessante
para quem está assistindo ao vivo por favor
sinta-se à vontade para  escreva qualquer pergunta vou
juntar minhas notas e vamos começar a
discussão
ok
bem primeiro apenas obrigado novamente pela
palestra
que tal um pouco de contexto sobre como você
veio a fazer essas perguntas em
sua posição atual e como seus
interesses nesta área se desenvolveram porque
há  tantas ideias interessantes e eu
só queria saber mais sobre como você
chegou a isso.
acho que estava escrevendo minha tese de
doutorado talvez em 2007 ou algo assim e uh eu
estava defendendo a ideia de que a
racionalidade deve ser algo que, em
última análise, está envolvido no mundo  em há uma
tendência a pensar bem mesmo entre como
eu disse como mostrei a vocês entre uh em
períodos encarnados com pessoas de certo
que precisa ser essencialmente
envolvendo o mundo, como atuação e prática
e assim por diante
e percepção, é claro, mas a racionalidade
permanece  algo como
noção naturalizável algo que não pode
ser reduzido ao nível do
não pode ser reduzido de uma forma
como a percepção que pode ser explicada
por um certo engajamento dinâmico e assim
por diante
então na época eu estava pensando bem
talvez este seja
um problema de joelho porque
em
outros contextos é levado a implicar que
qualquer percepção é se não for
articulada de forma a fornecer um
certo ajuste com combinação profissional,
então a percepção é um dado
e este é o mito da dimensão dada
no início e eu pensei
que bem talvez isso seja algo de
há algo de um mito do
dado trabalhando aqui em uma
cognição ativa mas isso não é eu acho  não é
fatal porque não poderíamos
argumentar que, em vez de
construir a percepção do passo e
outras formas básicas de combinações
envolvendo conceitos e afins, talvez
pudéssemos argumentar
de outra direção, tentar reduzir
a racionalidade em um nível mais não naturalizado
de
uh
então essa foi a motivação e foi
muito, foi um longo processo de revisão e
acredito que minha primeira versão
do artigo foi muito,
acho que eles estavam totalmente corretos. Eu
apoiei a sugestão afinal, mas ele
estava muito
uh  foram muito inflexíveis em tomar essa
parte e acho que foi para melhor
porque é outra literatura
é outra uh muitas referências
que não costumam estar em conversa com um
ativismo e reconhecimento corporal e foi
muito difícil apenas colocar o  importa
nos mesmos termos para avançar meus argumentos,
então é algo que eu risquei
e não pensei muito sobre
esse sistema, mas acho que é algo que eu
gostaria  para voltar e talvez uh
até provavelmente alguém o tenha feito
nos últimos anos não sei se me
lembro mas
esta relação entre um activismo o
mito da dádiva e parecia ser
parece ser muito
óbvio  então acho que é algo que
poderíamos, eu deveria dizer, ser capaz de
explorar, mas não há algo que
estava na frente do jornal,
mas eu tive essa ideia de falar sobre
racionalidade em todos os sentidos
e ao mesmo tempo  tempo eu estava lendo muito
sobre uh
liguei para ele de uma
perspectiva filosófica é claro que eu não sou como eu disse
muito bem versado nos aspectos técnicos
e nas formalidades da abordagem
mas eu estava interessado nas
consequências filosóficas lá e
pensei bem  talvez haja algo para
comparar aqui porque, como mostra a citação de Clark,
você pode falar sobre racionalidade o tempo
todo e isso é algo que eu
queria desenvolver, mas não em uma visão cognitivista, mas não em um
filme radicalmente incorporado, então
esse é o pano de fundo
incrível obrigado você poderia
descrever o que é o mito do
dado qual foi o contexto em que esse
mito surgiu e para onde vamos depois de
trazer o mito do dado
porque eu o vi como um conceito que  você
teceu então sobre o que era tudo
bem então no meio da
entrega existem vários dados possíveis
dependendo do seu gosto
de filosofia mas mais classicamente nos
campos anteriores da Mente tome o
conteúdo da percepção a ser dado  oração
racionalmente de uma forma que temos certas
entradas que são apenas recebidas pela
mente e a mente interpreta isso para que
vendedores diferentes vendedores sejam famosos por
uh
ter descrito seu uh este problema como
um problema não apenas para aumentar os combustíveis
da mente, mas também  para os racionalistas,
mas, por outro lado, racional é
geralmente tomado como intuição racional como um
dado, o que quer dizer que existe
algum nível de cognição
que é desarticulado.  é dado ou como algumas
pessoas falam sobre ser criado,
mas de certa forma há esse nível de
cognição que é dado e a mente tem
que interpretá-lo, mas se for dado
dessa maneira, não tem ponto de contato, não há
interseção entre o que quer que seja
o que quer que a mente faça e esse
nível básico de dominação, então minha ideia é
evitar a acusação de estar comprometido
com o mito do dado, mas novamente
isso não é algo explícito na
literatura nativista, mas é
algo que parece ser
possível desenvolver em um
quero dizer uh neste tipo de comparação, mas
não é não é do
não claramente lá, mas
uma maneira de resolvê-los para os
dados dizer que o conteúdo perceptual
já é de natureza conceitual, que é,
por exemplo, como Joe McDowell  tem em
mente o mais que você sabe uma
percepção uh a piada é vem com
legendas você e interpreta o mundo
como você faz mas uh
eu acho que de uma forma ou de outra
é desmistificar você sabe uma racionalidade  e
as camadas superiores de combinação tentam e
tentam pensar neles uh uh em menos
uh conteúdo para análise
sem comprometê-los então é estritamente
falando com um nível de conteúdo que é
divorciado dos níveis básicos de
combinação que é uma maneira que eu penso em
fazer isso e  racionalidade parece ser o
único conceito-chave para fazer isso porque
tudo é geralmente assumido como algo
exclusivamente humano e algo
relacionado ao raciocínio e bem, se for
assim, a racionalidade não pode informar a ação
e se, claro, a ação
for de natureza sem conteúdo  então, se a racionalidade
é um sentido essencialmente cheio de conteúdo e a
reação é essencialmente incontida para
sem conteúdo, então você pode não ter
isso,
uh, isso é feito, uh, interseção
entre dois domínios e isso é
algo que eu queria evitar, mas como eu
lhe disse, tornou-se tão difícil  expressar
essas opiniões de maneira
suficientemente clara e geral é
que, por recomendação de nosso revisor, eu
apago isso e
ainda penso em  mas nada que eu
não tenha desenvolvido uma
linha de argumentação adequada que lida com isso
mais claramente do que eu posso fazer como eu fiz
em termos muito gerais
legal bem algumas palavras que você associou
com racionalidade foram adaptabilidade
e também proficiência então o que você vê
como a relação de racionalidade e
aptidão
como uma função biológica certo sim sim
ok
eu acho que é uma
relação intrínseca realmente eu acho que é
provavelmente a
consequência mais óbvia da ação racional
em uma escala especial e quando
falamos se a racionalidade é uma característica
de certas espécies ou em vez de
indivíduos eu acho que a aptidão é um
dos conceitos-chave aqui para pensar isso
como o resultado dessa
ação racional,
então embora eu não diga que não
coloque nesses assuntos no papel eu
acho que é possível pensar
assim você sabe não vê isso
como uma objeção pensar pensar em
racionalidade mas novamente é muito liberal
e eu estou disposto a t  o aceitar essa
consequência também cada
organismo vivo de uma maneira se ele ainda não
se tornou Instinto, então está de uma maneira
ajustada ao seu ambiente, então estou disposto
a ver que pode envolver um
nível mínimo de racionalidade de  lidar com uh
o inimigo mudando o ambiente
mas bem e é o preço de ter uma
noção muito uh liberal Progressista de
racionalidades isso é uma consequência
disso Eu acredito
então você disse que Fitness é uma
consequência do Comportamento racional
existem outras consequências ou  como
reconhecemos a racionalidade do lado de fora,
além de apenas dizer que a
colônia de formigas está prosperando, na medida em
que é racional, é adaptativa uma
agência de exibição e tudo
isso é um
conceito de racionalidade tão deflacionário que todas as coisas existentes,
humanos e  caso contrário, são meramente
descritos por ele ou existem alguns
resultados que podemos usar para separar
como, por exemplo, um comportamento racional ou
irracional das meras
consequências refletidas por su  rvival and
Fitness
certo bem eu tive que pensar muito bem
sobre isso porque eu não
quero banalizar esse conceito de uma forma
que bem tudo é IPS de fato ou
racional pelo fato de que é
viver é relacionamento de atuação mas eu
acho que uh em casos particulares alguém
poderia uh identificar a nação que eu sou
igual aos indivíduos
um auto-sustentação nesse nicho então então
no nível individual em particular
ok isso é uma
ação conclusiva que poderia classificar
irracional na medida em que eles  uh
são prejudiciais para a sobrevivência, mas
uh no nível da espécie é mais
difícil argumentar dessa maneira
porque identificar esse tipo de comportamento ou
consequência, mas acho que
para não banalizar a ideia de
racional e dizer bem tudo o que é
viver é fatorado, você teria que
identificar esse tipo de atos específicos
que prejudicam
a sobrevivência,
então, no caso da colônia de formigas,
talvez eu não saiba
acolher invasores seria um
tipo de comportamento que
seria prejudicial para a
sobrevivência como tal
eu não sei eu não sei se isso é
uh é uma maneira impossível de pensar
sobre isso Eu tive que pensar mais claramente,
mas
meu  cuidadosamente
oh muito interessante e você
trouxe essa resposta e na apresentação
como várias
escalas de tempo aninhadas, assim como o Eco Evo
Devo faz de uma perspectiva mais biológica
, observando como a
construção de nichos preenche a lacuna entre
processos filogenéticos mais lentos e
processos de desenvolvimento mais
rápidos  como essa consideração
embutida e em várias escalas se
relaciona com o
conceito de conteúdo, como o conteúdo será
localizado em um corpo ou o conteúdo será
distribuído entre entidades ou a
racionalidade distribuída entre entidades,
como identificaríamos o locus
da racionalidade e que  também meio que
invoca a concepção horizontal e modular
da citação que você
forneceu, então como identificamos salientes
escalas temporais espaciais e sistemas de
interesse
oh ah eu não sei eu não sei se posso
responder uh isso completamente mas parece-me
que ao nível de uh se estamos a falar
de conteúdo por exemplo conteúdo como uma
precisão  condições para
pensamentos simbólicos acho que felizmente temos que
dizer que não está localizado em um
único indivíduo é compartilhado publicamente
então você pode dizer que
uma consequência disso é que é
possível pensar em diferentes
padrões de raciocínio que estão
sendo
sites de informação  em momentos diferentes Etc e você pode
ver que eles desenvolveram regras diferentes de
nível diferente para
informações de conteúdo
e eu acho que isso é
plausível dizer que o conteúdo
é localizado que o
uh como você pode dizer que é compartilhar a quantidade que
você conhece as especificidades de
apenas por racionalidade, acho que
alguém poderia
[Música]
identificar comportamentos específicos
se se encaixar nesses uh
esse tipo de descrição de uh spin
proficiente interação proficiente e
adaptativa  interação entre um organismo
e seu ambiente seu nicho então
provavelmente
poderíamos dar respostas diferentes aqui como
uma racionalidade e conteúdo Estou disposto
a dizer que
conteúdo para organização não é
algo que acontece na cabeça
algo que está lá fora de uma maneira
compartilhar  a quantidade de outros e isso é
algo que a minha filosofia
tem pelo menos desde os anos 60
os meus filósofos têm
defendido a ideia de que o conteúdo é individuado externamente
e uh eu sou eu acho que isso é um
dos vídeos de  por exemplo, Hillary Putnam
e Tyler Burge e outros que o
conteúdo mental é individualizado no
nível comunitário ou social,
mas por outro lado eles pensam que a
racionalidade poderia ser, em princípio,
individualizada em comportamentos particulares,
mas dependeria dos objetivos do indivíduo
e da  o nicho que habita e
assim por diante
, é claro que existem variáveis ​​reais
aqui que também podem ser importantes
para identificar o
comportamento  como racional ou não
ok
obrigado
hum bem, uma frase que realmente
me marcou foi como saber como não saber que
talvez seja um ponto básico em seu trabalho
e um foco nessa ação, então eu só
queria
ouvir sobre como a ação e a prática enquanto
você tecia  eles aqui hoje como esses
termos são abordados
e como as coisas são diferentes hoje com
o tratamento da ação e prática e
know-how não sei disso do que dizer no
helmholtzee em dias ou mesmo nas
tradições antigas ou do Conhecimento Mundial
Então Ok legal então a idéia  Eu
acho que
há uma tendência de uh, é uma
tendência de uma filosofia muito moderna,
mas tem sido muito influente na
primeira onda da ciência cognitiva para pensar
na percepção como
uma capacidade de categorizar o ambiente
e oferecer uma visão discreta  descrição de
aspectos ambientais então por exemplo
perceber que uh o o o
que eu sei que o copo está à minha esquerda é
uma questão de saber que existe uma
coisa com busca tais propriedades para
minha esquerda e isso é um tipo de uh sei
que um tipo de atitude proposicional em
relação ao mundo então
uh eu acho que a
coisa interessante sobre um ativismo e
psicologia ecológica também e na
medida em que eles lembram o
pragmatismo americano desde o início  o
século é pensar na
percepção como uma questão de não
categorizar essas grandes propriedades
no mundo, mas como uh revelar
possibilidades de atuação
e isso é algo que se a gente
explicasse isso em termos de uh em
termos epidêmicos como conhecimento nós não  t
coloco como uma questão de saber que a
curva está à minha esquerda, mas saber
pegar a xícara e fazer o que eu
quiser com ela se eu quiser tomar uma xícara de
café ou se eu quiser usá-la como
peso de papel ele terá diferentes
propriedades silenciosas e isso é algo
que,
embora tenha sido,
acho muito, acho que um ativismo e
psicologia ecológica e outras visões incorporadas da
cognição têm sido amplamente bem-sucedidas
na mudança  Levando essa discussão até este
ponto, acho que nas ciências cognitivas mais
tradicionais você ainda
tem a ideia de que
organismos bem organismos percebidos
descrevendo a maneira como o
ambiente é algo que eu acho que
as leituras mais tradicionais de
processamento preditivo deixam claro
como em uh a ideia de que você está inferindo
sobre a fonte de estímulos e não
em uh e não e isso não quero dizer que
isso é mais facilmente receptivo à ideia de
que o cérebro ou o
sistema cognitivo sabe que
o mundo é  assim e assim
o ambiente é assim e assim, em vez de
dizer que o sistema de agenda sabe como
se envolver com o mundo e acredito que
o ponto
que ativistas e psicólogos ecológicos
estão tentando fazer é
e também trabalhar no preditivo
codificação e o princípio da energia livre
Etc é mostrar que essas Noções esses
Frameworks poderiam ser uma ideia mínima de que
o sistema kubernetes é
saber engajar ele sabe engajar  ge no
ambiente de uma forma que não precisa
ser lido dentro do resumo
que o sistema Kindle está inferindo
que o mundo é assim, então eu acho que essa é
uma maneira de explicar, mas também
filosoficamente se você tiver um grande
no início de  nas últimas
décadas uh uma discussão gigantesca sobre
se nenhuma nuvem pode ser reduzida para
saber isso e então novamente você tem um
pano de fundo disso e de outro
como uma noção independente de você sabe
disso e se você pode
reduzir um ao outro e assim por diante  então
eu acho que não para por aí, você não pode
uh, embora eu possa fazer uma reivindicação de
percepção de outros sabendo como
eles ainda são a questão
de fundo de saber se o know-how pode ser tratado como
e tudo isso, de
qualquer maneira, isso é algo que  Também estou
trabalhando recentemente,
há muito a dizer,
é uma ideia tão interessante, especialmente com
comunicação linguística, é um
pouco como o dedo e a lua e
falando sobre a lua, mas o dedo é
apenas  onde está e não estamos falando
sobre o ponteiro, estamos falando sobre
a referência
e, portanto, usar
uma forma de comunicação sociocognitiva
na linguagem culta
ou no discurso acadêmico escrito para
perscrutar isso ou reimaginar isso e
ver até o que parece  ser como o
pináculo de saber isso
e ainda vê-lo como saber como
eu acho que a questão é
como lemos jornais
sim claro sim eu acho que é uh é
um
uh é sim os valores que parece ser
capaz de ser  um problema muito grande porque se
tentarmos tratar essas
capacidades negativas como você mencionou como uma questão
de know-
how parece que ainda falta algo
sobre comunicação por exemplo e
por outro lado eu acho que é minha
intuição mas eu acho  que poderíamos, em
princípio, falar sobre
como
entender o que você acabou de dizer e
tentar responder a isso é uma questão de
saber como se comportar linguisticamente,
mas acho que mesmo esse movimento
de tratar altos níveis de cognicionistas
que me fez  t uma questão de know-how
ainda deixa algo de fora em
que estou, quero dizer, pessoalmente, estou
e estou satisfeito com isso, acho que em algum
nível temos que dizer que, bem,
esse é outro tipo de abordagem necessária
aqui para explicar como  comunicar por
exemplo em
muito adequado para não dizer que
não envolve e agora mas não é só
que eu acho que pelo menos mais do que
conhecimento prático é necessário
mas talvez a chave aqui seja pensar em
conhecimento prático apenas básico e
necessário para outros tipos  de outros
tipos de conhecimento que eles são necessários
para se envolver neste tipo de troca
talvez talvez esta seja uma camada
eu tenho certeza que
bem
uh mais tem que ser
dito sobre isso para dar uma
resposta mais informativa, mas isso é
pelo menos minha posição atual é que
nenhum como fornece a base de nosso
envolvimento com o mundo e com os
outros, mas em algum momento temos
que ser capazes de desenvolver outros tipos de
compreensão para explicar muito explicar
os tipos complexos de uh  trocas que
temos no nosso dia a
dia como ler jornais como você disse
eu concordo acho que
enquadrar o saber como base e depois
recuperar o saber fazer é um desafio
e também é um desafio começar com os
processos cognitivos basais como sendo
decretado sem casa e  remontar essas
peças de know-how em saber que, novamente
, não é necessariamente um
desafio simples, mas preferimos enfrentar
o desafio de montar processos cognitivos
proposicionais declarativos verbais
etc. simbólicos a partir de uma
abordagem cognitiva ecológica mais liminar
ou tentar recuperar o ecológico
da turing  máquina em certo sentido, então
parece que
você está falando em apoio à fundamentação
em processos cognitivos basais plausíveis ecológicos
e, em seguida, trabalhando para
montar o arranha-céu
sim sim sim totalmente sim eu acho que é
bom
ambas as abordagens são difíceis
de montar  como você disse para fornecer
esse tipo de explicação no
canto inferior esquerdo ou de cima para baixo, mas eu  sou mais
favorável naturalmente à abordagem da web
penso que também por outra
razão parece ao ponto de
partida parece ser
uma descrição biológica de como
interagimos com o mundo e o
contrário parece ser muito mais
difícil  para explicar uh como chegamos
a essas questões biológicas,
como a morfologia do nosso corpo e tal, parece
que primeiro temos que explicar isso
e então chegamos às outras
questões que também são difíceis de
responder, mas no próprio  pelo menos eu acho
que é
uma abordagem de baixo para cima é mais uh
integrativa de certa forma é que as chances
são de que parece ser mais
uh a nosso favor no sentido
e e a maneira como você meio que enquadrou
isso me fez pensar que se você fosse  para
programar um computador do zero
ele pode ser um computador abstrato ou virtual,
então nem precisa ter
uma personificação específica
e nessa situação pode-se estar
preocupado em montar
know that assert that e montar
esses declare
declarações ativas e processos lógicos em
algo que é mais dinâmico ou em
interação com o ambiente, no entanto,
esse processo de engenharia de pilha completa
com lógica e silicone na base
é bem diferente de como chegamos aqui
e pode, mas é
complementar,
bem  você deu um pouco de visibilidade
para uh, eu acho que o antes durante e
depois da revisão por pares, então eu estava
curioso para saber o que
mudou durante e depois do artigo, como
nos últimos meses ou anos ou por
quanto tempo você evoluiu sobre isso
e depois o que  considera os
próximos passos relevantes quer sejam para si ou
apenas para serem feitos em geral estamos à procura
de uma medição do cérebro estamos à procura
de uma câmara de vídeo numa floresta estamos à
procura de um conceito Avançar o que
vai passar para a frente  seus
desenvolvimentos
essa é uma ótima pergunta eu acho
hum
eu não estou completamente satisfeito com a
maneira que eu vou usar o nível estrangeiro não
sei se isso seria
realizado  t em uh eu honestamente não sei
se você poderia em princípio realizado em
outros termos empíricos mas
uh eu não estou dizendo que uh bem
um é que eu escreveria um pouco
diferente hoje não que não seja uh não
que eu discorde do  artigo
originalmente, mas acho que
há algo alguns pontos que eu
gostaria de reformular, mas eles não
autorizam uh também acho que ele tinha um novo
artigo,
mas talvez no futuro, mas isso é
algo que
as perguntas como o mito
deram que é  ainda a questão filosófica
e conceitual eles ainda uh me incomodam,
mas eu ainda tenho
que encontrar a oportunidade de desenvolver essas
idéias com mais cuidado e a visão geral que
eu apresentei lá eu acho que eu acho
que ainda se mantém
uh, mas
hum,
eu gostaria que eu eu  ainda estou à espera
desta oportunidade para a elaborar melhor e
ver até onde posso chegar mas ainda não
sei devo admitir que não sei quais são
os desenvolvimentos futuros desta ideia
mas tenho andado a trabalhar  em vários
assuntos isolados  s nesta abordagem
nos últimos anos eu trabalhei com
a noção de informação e
compreensão científica e informação para
ativistas ecológicos e de
combinação e recentemente estou trabalhando
mais recentemente com algumas faculdades em
realidade virtual e
reconhecimento de percepção então uh
isso  é como eu gosto de conduzir minha
pesquisa para encontrar
perguntas interessantes e ver como posso lidar
com elas, mas não necessariamente
me
encontrar preso a
uma linha de raciocínio dessa maneira, então foi
isso que aconteceu na época em que eu estava
trabalhando  racionalidade se eu achasse que
era um assunto muito legal e uh eu ainda
acho que é mas eu não tive tempo
de voltar e reformular o que eu
queria mas uh talvez talvez em
um futuro próximo eu não sei, mas mais  a
coisa mais recente em que tenho trabalhado
não envolve a racionalidade celular,
mas acho que alguns produtos
podem estar errados, que é a
realidade virtual e
como a realidade visual realmente se
compara a com  binação porque
bem, obviamente, está faltando algo
em uma perseverança e um
ambiente visual, certo
, é claro, se eu alguém, por
exemplo, se estou em um
ambiente visual onde estou sob um tipo de
ameaça, posso sentir algo análogo ao
medo, mas  Eu não estou realmente temendo pela minha
vida
e imagino que a pessoa na
realidade virtual então é racional
fugir da
ameaça a ameaça virtual e assim
por diante isso é isso é isso
que eu estou trabalhando  e uh talvez
seja um ponto de retorno a
esta ideia de racionalidade radical e ativa
e de fato uh o papel
acabou de ser aceito então como eu estava
dizendo antes eu estava tão ocupado nos últimos
dias porque estávamos corrigindo provas
meu  colegas e eu nunca figurativo
uh e eu também estava
com o cronograma apertado
para enviar a versão corrigida do
paper nas últimas semanas e aí eu
peguei as provas e
ah
uh bem talvez uh no futuro eu possa
voltar ao assunto  ue de racionalidade
eu gostaria mas não sei se eu
não sei eu realmente não posso prever os
desenvolvimentos disso mas uh em geral eu
ainda concordo com a minha ideia original mas
vou emoldurar um pouco diferente  pouco
para o ponto de VR, tenho certeza de que há
muito mais a dizer lá, mas me
lembrou apenas o título realidade virtual é uma
virtualização e, da mesma forma
que
o planejamento de ação cognitiva
nos permite entreter
políticas que nosso corpo não  t
tomar apenas para avaliá-los e escolher
contra eles, mas podemos ir em um vôo
de fantasia ter um
processo de seleção de políticas caprichosas
de contrafactuais
mentalmente,
mas então nossa morfologia é como
nossa linha de vida, você sabe se você realmente
cair de uma borda, então é  vai doer
e então na realidade virtual
você está incorporado a
experiência perceptiva é literalmente
uma virtualização de
situações críticas de sobrevivência então você
pode se ver como estando em uma borda
mas você está em um chão plano
e então nessa situação
se você é um tipo de
observador cognitivo fora do
videogame, pode dizer que é
racional para mim apenas cair para ver o
que acontece,
então é assim, mas há uma camada
de racionalidade dentro do espaço sim, como o
que é uma boa jogada  no jogo
hum e então está meio que borrando a linha
entre
[Música
] está borrando a criticidade
do corpo e hum,
eu tenho certeza que você pensou sobre isso muito
mais, então como isso se encaixa em nossa
realidade virtual
hum com o  maneiras como pensamos, usamos
e projetamos esses sistemas
bem, essas são as
perguntas que nos motivaram a escrever um
artigo e a NADA deu a eles e eu era
que na literatura técnica você vê
que muitos pesquisadores trabalhando com
o  uh trate uh percepção visual como
illustri um tipo de ilusão mas ficamos
um pouco incomodados com isso porque por
outro lado só funciona em VR
porque incorporamos os dispositivos dispositivos que eles
trabalham para nós você tem os controladores você
tem a cabeça  set
e uh parece tão estranho dizer que o
usuário o usuário está sob uma espécie de
ilusão
e por outro lado parece que não é
realmente cognição porque como você
disse não há não há
relevância biológica para aqueles uh cognitivos
Afirma, por assim dizer, por exemplo, se eu vejo
uma maçã em VR, ela não fornece
nutrição, mas faz sentido dentro do
jogo, certo, mas a diferença,
bem, eu recebi uma maçã em um
ambiente real, ela fornece
nutrição  é algo que eu posso comer
mas não em VR eu posso fingir então nós
cunhamos esse uh conceito de alusão ao
seu plano
uh é como se estivéssemos
diante de um animal real mas envolve
também essa vontade de brincar essa ideia de
que não somos
sendo enganado porque colocamos o
equipamento sabemos que estamos no jogo e
isso eu acho que é um assunto quente agora
porque há metáforas e sou muito
cético em relação ao
que puder as pessoas estão muito otimistas, mas
sobre as possibilidades do metave  rse
e alguns autores realmente pensam que
poderíamos estar em uma simulação
estritamente falando, mas quero dizer que a melhor
tecnologia que a tecnologia atual
nos mostra é que é muito limitada e você pode
fingir estar em um determinado ambiente
e assim por diante e isso eu acho  pode
oferecer novas maneiras de
pensar sobre a racionalidade neste
ambiente visual de maneiras que talvez os
russos façam algo que o
ambiente disse para pular da borda e ver o
que acontece e, por outro lado
, aspectos comportamentais de fazê-lo às vezes as
pessoas realmente sentem  o medo e as pessoas
enfrentam a rua por fobias com
realidades
virtuais e é muito, há muitas
perguntas interessantes lá que
talvez eu queira dizer para pesquisas futuras, podemos
sim voltar a isso me fez pensar sobre
como a Apple na vida real é  poderia ser
calorias para você mas também poderia ser
calorias para uma mosca poderia ser jogada
você poderia usá-la como um martelo você poderia
pintar direito então a
ecologia e o generativo  processo, como
diríamos, um tipo de inferência ativa
está sempre indo Além de
quaisquer affordances que foram programadas
para um determinado objeto e também
o discurso atual sobre VR se concentra
fortemente em fones de ouvido,
apenas falando totalmente anedótico, não
não é minha área de especialização
, parece um  pouco
interessante é como se a
discussão sobre o telemóvel estivesse apenas focada em
rectângulos de um certo tamanho o
que torna isto não realidade virtual é
como olhar através de uma janela e
há outro colega com quem falar por isso
não está ligado à minha cabeça não
temos algumas das
capacidades de rastreamento de movimento que algumas tecnologias
têm, mas é
uma modificação de nicho no espaço pessoal de Perry
e podemos empurrar
sinais e affordances uns para os outros,
então ter um enquadramento VR ou realmente apenas um
enquadramento de racionalidade e percepção
cognição ação Ciclos
que
não são apenas restritos a uma
realização específica ou tipo de hardware e podem executar
a gama de pessoa total offline
em um campo
para s  alguém que está muito
em Matrix
parece bastante relevante, caso contrário, novas
tecnologias, mesmo pequenas variantes e
atualizações de software, continuarão a
surpreender e confundir infinitamente,
sim, eu acho que é difícil
definir os limites,
quero dizer, estamos aqui em uma troca
que  Eu acho que poderia aumentar, mas ser
classificado como uma forma de realidade virtual é
claro que estou vendo você arruinar sua mente C,
mas
uh, quero dizer, a maioria eu acho que funciona eles
hoje em dia eles acham um doc
dizendo que bem deve ter um fone de ouvido  e
às vezes um controlador, mas
fora isso parece realidade virtual, mas
sim, é difícil definir qualquer coisa, uh
, não é, não é um lixo e
direto, isso é uma das coisas
porque, uh falando comercialmente, é
claro, realidade virtual significa fones de ouvido
e outras parafernálias, mas mas  um
telefone apenas falando ao telefone ou um
telégrafo naquela época
estaria nessa interface com essa
modalidade sensorial e com essas affordances
é  a virtualização
sim a que temos acesso de apenas um
capítulo diferente hoje
sim eu acho que sim parte do nosso trabalho
foi argumentar que de certa forma incorporar
dispositivos tecnológicos é
obviamente necessário não isso não é novo é a
marca do Ser
Humano é  incorporando dispositivos tecnológicos o
que nos tornou o que somos desde o
início usando a tecnologia analítica e
o fato de que podemos incorporá-lo de forma tão
proficiente como um dispositivo, mesmo que esteja
programado para, por exemplo, dentro da
realidade virtual para ter algo uma
criatura com a qual você nos controla mais rico  nova
morfologia outra morfologia, por
exemplo, mesmo que seja esse o caso, isso só
acontece com tanta proficiência porque somos
capazes de incorporar o dispositivo, alguns
experimentos mostraram que você pode mapear,
por exemplo, uma torção do pulso para um
terceiro braço
uh, a realidade individual foi
que do seu peito e as pessoas podem
aprender a controlar esse terceiro braço que
não mapeia em nossa morfologia real,
mas pode ser feito por um Twist o  para o
pulso, então
isso é algo que discutiremos em
nosso artigo que bem,
você pode fazer isso porque você incorpora
o dispositivo, você pode ver que é uma
ilusão, na verdade,
parte do que eu sou humano é
bordar dispositivos tecnológicos, então
eu  iria dessa forma, quero dizer, eu sei que isso
confunde a distinção entre
botões virtuais e não virtuais, acho que é uma
maneira de lidar com isso
legal, há mais alguma coisa que você queira
falar, pergunte ou apenas um tipo de Prelúdio,
ah bem, eu gostaria  gostaria de agradecer pela
oportunidade de discutir este artigo foi
muito bom para mim eu realmente gostei
e este é um ambiente muito agradável e
confortável para discutir essas
questões e pensar obrigado mais uma vez
obrigado sim ótima discussão e
tópicos importantes e  ficaremos felizes em
falar com você novamente a qualquer momento
ok obrigado adeus obrigado